eu tenho a honra de participar de um
coletivo que levar a educação pra dentro
dos presídios
quero pedir licença para convidar para
subir ao palco junto comigo 2.800 homens
que encontram se em privação de
liberdade e 860 mulheres que também
encontram-se intervação de liberdade
eu tenho a honra de uma vez por semana
me encontrar com esses homens em com
essas mulheres e uma oficina de criação
literária em uma das nossas conversas
falamos sobre educação e surgiram várias
inquietações neste neste momento e eu
pedi pra que eles me processem palavras
que remetessem à educação pra eles e um
desafio foi com as palavras que eles
trouxeram criar uma poesia para
apresentar hoje pra vocês especialmente
e é a forma em que eu os convido para
participar comigo neste momento todo o
conhecimento é trilhar pra evolução
a educação é sabe para transformação com
força e disposição vamos juntos
construir um futuro vencedor
por isso estamos aqui estamos aqui para
aprender e um mundão nos ensina a
trabalhar com um empate a autocontrole
disciplina partilhando o amor de forma
incondicional
liberdade de expressão é amar o desigual
nesta vida infelizmente existe muita
humilhação mas com educação faremos
revolução emoção à flor da pele seja
branca seja preta passamos nós a
diferença mas se for preta não se
esqueça é treta preta
de domésticas a doutora as guerreiras
quilombolas de pedreiro a professores
vamos mudando nossa história com
respeito paciência e muita dedicação
sorriso de criança também é revolução
procedessem violência nos motiva a
seguir
armados de carinho não vamos desistir
muitos no esquecimento nos não deixaram
de sonhar
essa é nossa gente nos motivando a lutar
por uma nova realidade cultura como
prioridade onde haja esperança para
todas as idades
em meio à multidão sigo com minha missão
fazer da educação a única ostentação e
pra você cadeia rima com educação
esta poesia prova que sim para quem
pensou que não
haverá um dia onde todos os presídios
serão jardins onde nossas crianças
poderão livremente brincar mas para que
esse dia seja realidade é necessário que
a educação esteja presente em todos os
espaços inclusive dentro dos presídios
muito obrigada
[Aplausos]